3d gesture control technology has been a
big emerging trend here at CES 2012
we've already seen it in Microsoft's
Kinect in samsung announced it would
also have gesture control in its
upcoming Smart TV platform we decided to
take a look at a few smaller companies
and see where gesture control technology
is headed in the future this is Leonardo
a new kind of 3d modeling software it's
really cool because it lowers the
learning curve 3d modeling is normally
really hard you've got to know a lot of
math a lot of programming with this it's
all about your artistic abilities you're
basically carving your 3d model in the
air using a kind of stylist called a
bird you also wearing 3d glasses and
their sensors that send on your computer
screen that perform I tracking right now
it's being used by some universities and
medical facilities a basic purchase is a
thousand dollars and that includes the
bird the sensors the eyeglasses and the
software we're here at soft kinetic
checking out there near mode interaction
prototype basically it's going to bring
connect like gesture controls to your
laptop in the coming year will see it as
a clip-on for your laptop kind of like a
webcam the year after that though it'll
be built into laptops South kinetics
depth sense technology can detect
objects as close as 15 centimeters
connect on the other hand 50 centimeters
as the closest you can get soph kinetic
software can also detect more details
like your individual fingers so this
could be used to replace mouse controls
and keyboard controls 3d modeling and
controlling our desktop and notebook
computers are just a few ways we'll see
3d gesture technology being used in the
future we'll have to see CES 2013 how
far this technology really goes
you